j'accueille maintenant le bol du psg
alias monsieur simeone dominique
casagrande
dominique casagrande bonsoir vous
connaissez tous le monde julie depardieu
le hockey c'est déjà plus la cote elle
veut changer de place a pu me dire qu'il
était bon c'est sympa store merci
samy naceri eric raoult et lynda lemay
la nouvelle coqueluche de paris et
alexandre jardin
comme chaque année nous fessons millions
d'exemplaires de livres et 100 millions
de téléspectateurs de file alors mesure
1 m 89 peser 82 kg pas mal
alors samedi dernier le psg s'est
qualifié pour sa troisième finale de la
coupe de la ligue en éliminant bastia 4
à 2 alors le psg sera opposé le 22 avril
au fc gueugnon au stade de france c'est
quand même bizarre que des clubs comme
gueugnon mais ça me surprend toujours
illégal et il gagne on commet des petits
clubs comme ça il va à se retrouver face
à des grands clubs comme le psg civile à
quoi ça veut dire que tous les bons
joueurs sont à l'étranger ou pas pour
résumer c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est
que thomas walser sur l'étranger et le
niveau perdu le championnat français est
en train de baisser
bah oui il faudrait peut-être
s'inquiéter c'est peut-être pas les
petits qui sont plus forts c'est
peut-être les grands qui sont mauvais
ouais donc c'est ça l'histoire c'est
peut-être sa pratique c'est des
compétitions celle là qui se joue sur un
match ou à des matches aller retour donc
c'est pas comme un championnat le psg
joue pas contre gueugnon contre khaled
en championnat français c'est sur un
match que ces équipes-là joue tout sur
un match j'imagine des petites équipes
oui mais ça fait longtemps que c'est
comme ça donc c'est pas nouveau c'est ce
qui est nouveau c'est qu'ils arrivent au
bout maintenant et qui sont à présent
d'un une demi finale et une finale en
jeu 22 avril au stade de france pouvait
nous faire battre par gueugnon mais sûr
je pense pas mais c'est un peu vrai tu
répètes c'est à dire continuer sa
famille si je dis des conneries
à l'époque le psg
1 m 80 époque le psg perdait tout le
temps donc je sais que c'était une
passoire et puis comme sa nana elle
présentait la météo toutes les filles
qui préfèrent météo sa femme pardon
c'est peut-être pas votre femme encore à
l'époque d'ailleurs mais mais en tout
cas votre fiancée j'ai dit oui c'était
une gourde qui épousa une passoire
c'était méchant je vais faire comme eric
raoult et je fais mon mea culpa et je
regrette et ça sera pas dans mon best of
à la famille
c'était pour faire un mot sans être
n'importe quel goût amer et n'importe
quand j'étais petit ça va épurer
n'importe quel gardien de but parce
qu'en fait je ne vais jamais vu jouer et
il serait exactement il serait peut être
n'importe quelle fille qui présente la
météo mais c'est pas une passoire
c'est un gardien c'est un très bon gars
des problèmes avec l'ama mais on va y
venir j'y vois là bas tu penses bien
vous avez commencé à taper dans un
ballon à l'âge de 4 ans est relativement
jeune et après aux effets championnat de
france universitaire de rugby 3e ligne
et aujourd'hui vous aimez toujours bien
de rugby parce que vous regardez les
matchs de rugby à la télé et le foot
vous regardez que les résumés
mais c'est vrai que c'est peut-être ya
peut-être trop de foot à la télé donc
c'est plus facile de regarder les
résumés ouais mais j'ai une passion
c'est le rugby et c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément plaisir de les voir jouer
tout le week-end alors en 94 jouer à
murer sacrée toulouse c'est ça la vie
les domaines de toulouse de muret du mur
et vous êtes de muret ah bon parcours un
muret coupe de france vous êtes
finalement échoué contre monaco 1-0 et
vous ai fait un bon match et klinsmann
qui avait marqué le but c'est ça la met
à saigner et donc le match j'ai joué un
match assez bon d'ailleurs vous avez
contre vous djorkaeff thuram petit
ettori et donc là vous commencez à être
un peu draguer par les par les clubs les
autres clubs dont nantes
et quand vous arrivez à nantes vous êtes
champion de france la première les la
haye d'après demi finale ligue des
champions il vous est suspendu à ce
moment là pour blessure il ya un titre
qui prend votre place s'appelle mickaël
landreau qui prend votre place
et là ça commence ay là il a fini la
saison quoi mais tout à fait normal
parce qu'il a précieux qu'il a pris ma
place bus étaient suspendus pub et c'est
bien réussie l'équipe tournait bien ne
permet plus donc c'est pas une petite
durée c'est une longue durée donc c'est
tout à fait normal que sa saison puisque
ça se passait bien à laurent soir vous
êtes un type de décision envoie un soir
mercredi soir on vous propose d'aller
jouer à seville vous partez le jeudi et
samedi vous faites votre premier match
voilà c'est vrai pas sur un coup de tête
parce qu'on y réfléchisse quand même
pendant toute la nuit
ouais mais c'est vrai que c'est une
expérience que j'ai voulu tenter l'essai
en mairie vous avez passé une année
formidable à seville il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont
au foot là bas quarante deux mille
personnes pour de la d2 c'est énorme en
faveur que pour ce à quoi pour le reste
la fête à la limite
ouais vous allez donc vous êtes à vous
êtes assez ville et vous êtes recruté
par le psg à lorient 98 donc biétry vous
propose de devenir la doublure c'est
comme ça qu'on dit non c'est un journal
télévisé sur le joker vous sur la
doublure de l'ama et ils vous donnent
ils vous donnent transfert et 5 millions
je crois donc vous dites vous dit j m ce
prix là c'est vraiment je vais jouer
quoi ah non non non à cette époque là
tout était clair charles biétry m'a fait
venir mais ça nous fait bien les choses
que je serai remplaçant de verre l'arma
et donc ça c'était la première année et
donc j'étais que prêté par le club
espagnol
c'est la deuxième année où je suis
racheté par le psg où là on nous
signifie qu'ils voient une concurrence
avec bernard la main ouais il ya eu ce
qui s'est passé basser vous ai dit
montrons enfin vous êtes dit j'ai été
trompé ouais ouais voilà c'est vrai que
j'ai pensé aux mains mais à part m'a
menti un peu comme virenque
vous avez dit on m'a menti javier la
haine quand même l'entretien en colère
c'est vrai qu'on a la haine parce que je
fais un métier où on a envie de jouer
ouais j'ai passé un an resté sur le banc
à cirer de bain qui vous ont acheté pour
vous mettre sur le banc de touche quoi
oui voilà
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut toujours de
garder dans un club et après quand on
regarde les résultats c'est vrai que ça
donne raison aux dirigeants puisque
bernard lama fait une très bonne saison
et être en pétard contre la masse est un
con je le mets est à jamais un pétard
contre travers la lentille souhaite
quand même
non parce qu'on a une bonne discussion
porterait à s'interposer au départ c'est
facile de monter toujours là prêt de
monter des petites phrases tout ça et à
son initiative dans une bonne discussion
entre cadieux et ça s'est très bien
terminée et alors là maintenant c'est
réglé quoi en décembre 99 vous avez
votre votre contrat et l'ama est parti
non mais toujours là dans ma part en fin
d'année oui et je lui qui est sur le
banc de touche maintenant nous allons
nous nourrir
très content lui crachait les à vos
classiques tirés à partir d un autre
club
c'est là encore qu'est ce qui fait alors
la main oui mais actuellement il joue
lui qui joue la coupe de la ligue et en
fin de saison mais bernard continuera sa
carrière dans un autre club dans nos
pays on sait pas ça ne me regarde pas
absolument pas et moi je serai à paris
pour débuter après sur les cartes en
main avant d'être bol si je suis bon
tout va bien je suis pas mauvais qu'en
fermant à ce que dit rich & g cham elle
dit ça tu as été bien ce soir enfin je
dis ça pour faire un bon outil à lundi
il a dit qu'il était très bon ben voilà
alors quand tout va bien je dis mon pote
parole et s'acquitte bien de toi je sais
fois j'avais la fleur du moins bien on
va repartir de bon ça va là ah ouais ça
votre serge tu peux me faire la question
qui tue la s'il te plaît
est ce que vous êtes sûr d'être
titulaire l'année prochaine oui
absolument
on est sûr mais de débuter titulaire
c'est le premier match après c'est à moi
de montrer ce que je vaux et et on verra
bien ce jour là mais shops à nouveau sur
des mythes est bon on peut allumer du pg
qui allait débarquer
tu vois et que d'aller y apprendre l'art
difficile bien sûr c'est tout à fait
normal que c'est comment on ne sait pas
encore le club cherche ici
le club cherche mais les sites soit fait
normal et c est chercher alors là on
rigole plus on va passer au blind thèse